good morning hickets tuesday in the
united states if you're 75 years old and
contract covet 19 you have
on average well over a 90 chance of
surviving if you're my age even if you
have a couple pre-existing health
conditions like i do your chances of
surviving are over 98
that's your personal risk but there's a
big difference between
personal risk and societal risk like one
simple way of imagining this is that if
one percent of americans died tomorrow i
would almost certainly
not die but 3.3 million people would and
so my personal risk might be
low but societally it would still be
catastrophic
now the reality of covet is of course
less simple for one thing it doesn't
only cause death it can also cause
severe illness and long-term health
complications
but also the disease does not infect or
sicken or kill people at random
infectious disease never treats people
equally because
our social orders don't treat people
equally and so in the united states we
see for instance far higher rates of
mortality among people of color we also
have to consider the disease itself like
in the 1918 flu pandemic middle-aged
adults were most likely to die with this
pandemic older adults are most likely to
die
and so it's not random because of
disparities in our socioeconomic order
and disparities in our healthcare system
and because of the disease itself
more vulnerable people have more
personal risk which i would argue makes
the societal risk higher but some people
seem to be arguing makes the societal
risk
lower okay so our responses to the
pandemic also come with personal and
societal risks right like there are
risks to disrupted educations and
decreased economic activity
and increased isolation and so on these
costs are huge and again they reflect
inequities in our social order and so
are not distributed at random but i
would argue their root cause is not
government regulation their root cause
is the disease like government
restrictions are not the only factor
affecting human behavior even where bars
and theaters are open people are less
likely to patronize them as long as
indoor massless gatherings are known to
spread a highly infectious novel disease
and it's not at all clear that keeping
everything open actually reduces these
costs
of the pandemic like sweden for instance
implemented far fewer public health
measures than neighboring norway and as
a result has a coveted death rate that's
over 10 times higher but sweden's
economy has actually suffered
more than norway's and then maybe most
critically there are the societal risks
that accompany an overwhelmed health
care system like when sierra leone had
an ebola outbreak in 2014 the health
care system collapsed and as a result
there was a huge
increase in mortality more mothers dying
in childbirth more children dying of
dire real illnesses and so on
and so as one doctor put it to me most
people who died of ebola
did not die of ebola they died because
the health care system got overwhelmed
now the kovit-19 pandemic is very
different but uncontrolled spread of
kovid will also lead and in some cases
is currently leading to an overwhelmed
healthcare system
if there are too many patients for
doctors and nurses to treat or not
enough hospital beds or inadequate
supplies
people will die of health issues that in
normal times
would have been survivable and so one of
the reasons the societal risk of covid19
is so high is the stress it places on
the healthcare system itself and one of
the reasons to try to slow transmission
is to lessen the unconscionable burden
currently being placed on healthcare
workers
not everyone has a choice about whether
to be exposed to covid19 at work or
whether to be exposed while engaging in
daily activities but this week
many americans will have a choice many
of us will have a choice about whether
to expose ourselves and those we love to
covet 19 at the thanksgiving dinner
table
the personal risk to you in that choice
may be low although it's not that low
but the societal risk is very very high
we know kovitt is real we know it killed
over 10 000 americans last week and we
know
safe and effective vaccines are coming
so please if you have a choice
choose to stay home hank i'll see you on
friday
because i love you and so you can't come
to thanksgiving
next year though next year there will be
feasting
and dancing in jerusalem next year